[Music]
hey guys it's Justine and I am so
excited because I actually just got back
from Seattle I went to visit Microsoft I
mean I flew into Seattle but then we
went to Redmond since that's where their
headquarters is located and I've been
here before but I've never done an
actual full tour of Microsoft so we got
to see so many amazing things I filmed a
bunch of content but I filmed it all in
vertical because I was kind of in that
Tick Tock and YouTube shorts mindsets
like there's all sorts of things that go
into product making that I don't think
people really think about and I kind of
have some background in product making
and graphic design and those types of
things but this is a whole nother level
I mean there's different departments for
every single thing for color for
textiles like I didn't ever think that
there's a textiles department at
Microsoft when you think about it there
is soft textiles on some of their
surface products on the covers on the
actual laptops themselves so small
little details have to be put in place
to actually make all of these things so
it's kind of cool go in and see all of
these different departments working
together I just love their attention to
detail now the whole reason that we were
actually there is because they are
releasing some new Surface products and
I am
huge surf service fan and I know all of
the Apple Fans out there like Justine
but we thought you were team Apple yes I
am but if you're new here and have only
seen some of my Apple content I've been
covering pretty much all facets of
technology and I'm such a huge fan of
surface and one of the reasons that I
love Apple so much is their attention to
detail and for their incredible design
and I think that's something that
surface has really paid such close
attention to is their attention to
detail their attention to design and
just the overall aesthetic of their
products is it's top-notch like I
absolutely love it especially the
surface Studio I've been such a huge fan
of this I actually had a little
flashback while I was at Microsoft
thinking of when I first got that
service Studio I was unboxing it in my
kitchen for some reason I don't know why
that's why I chose to to unbox it but I
did and that is such an incredible
device but since I started with a studio
they now have the new studio 2 plus and
here it is it looks very similar to the
previous models which is something that
Microsoft intentionally did because this
design already is so great and people
love it and one of the things that
they've heard from customers is there's
really not much that they want changed
about this design at least in this
current form I do feel like there will
be a studio three and I think that's
where maybe they'll push the envelope a
little bit but the studio 2 this whole
form factor and everything about it I
absolutely love now I have started doing
more illustration recently so now I'm
really excited kind of coming at this
from another perspective to really see
what this is like to use for
illustration so here it is this is the
surface Studio 2 plus this has a large
28 inch pixel sense touch screen and
really the key thing with this device is
the fact that you can basically lower
and raise the display with the zero
gravity hinge this does come with
Windows 11 and it features an 11th gen
Intel Core h35 processor the surface
Studio 2 plus has up to 50 faster CPU
speeds than service Studio 2 and it's
five times more powerful than the
original Studio it has double the
graphics performance in surface Studio 2
with the Nvidia GeForce RTX 3060 laptop
GPU it's optimized for Windows 11 and it
has USBC with Thunderbolt 4. it has
enhanced cinematic viewing and sound
with Dolby vision and Dolby Atmos and as
far as storage it has a one terabyte
solid state drive now in addition to the
surface Studio 2 plus they also had the
new Surface laptop 5 and the Surface Pro
9. we also got a chance to get a little
sneak peek at some of the Microsoft
adaptive accessories and this is
something that I'm so excited about the
things that Microsoft has been doing
even dating back to the Adaptive
controller for Xbox has been incredible
and they have this whole adaptive lab
where they actually bring in people in
the community and able to get real-time
feedback it was a really cool experience
to really get a chance to see this this
new lab was built with inclusivity in
mind so this is what the Adaptive Mouse
Hub and the buttons look like so you
basically are able to create a mouse
that's unique to you so you can explore
all of the different ways you can
customize this these components all work
together there's the mouse core a tail
extension and a thumb support so you're
able to create a traditional Mouse it's
light and portable or you can use just
that little tiny one all by itself it's
super easy to pair you can just connect
the mouse core wirelessly and up to
three different devices through a USBC
connection so let's take a look at the
new Surface Pro 9s obviously since
Windows 11 is out all of these are
shipping with Windows 11 which is very
exciting the Surface Pro 9s come with an
Intel 12 gen processors that are all
built on the Intel Evo platform these
come in four colors there's a platinum
graphite Sapphire and Forest and I am
obsessed with this Forest color it's so
pretty I can't even handle it something
new in the Surface Pro 9 lineup is
there's actually a 5G version this time
and the 5G does only come in the
platinum and you can see here the 5G is
a little different because you can see
the 5G antenna bands here where on the
previous version and the Wi-Fi only all
of the antenna bands are actually hidden
so you can't actually see them but of
course 5G does need a little extra help
in that department so that's why you're
able to see them here now this version
of the surface is is like this
absolutely just beautiful blue cover
it's also laser etched with this awesome
design now this is a partnership with
Liberty there and london-based Global
design house and since service is
celebrating their 10 years they did this
awesome collaboration it has this
vibrant blue floral design that's
inspired by the windows 11 Bloom and
it's available in select markets only at
Liberty and Microsoft stores and while
supplies last I hope those supplies last
long enough for me to get my little
fingers on one of these because it's so
beautiful the pattern is engraved and it
matches the keyboard and it's just so
pretty I can't get over it I really love
the Surface Pro 9 displays it has a 120
hertz refresh rate it's also got an HD
camera omnisonic speakers directional
microphones and their custom G6 chip
that allows you to take inking to the
next level with tactile signals so when
you're actually using the surface pen
it'll actually feel like you're writing
on paper and it's such a cool feeling to
have that haptic feedback with the new
Microsoft sq3 processor it'll unlocks
new AI features that were made possible
through an entirely new neural
Processing Unit it was really cool to
see they have this new thing called eye
contact so when you're actually on a
webcam call and when you're looking at
your display it'll actually make your
eyes look like it's looking at the
webcam so it'll feel more personal to
people who are actually watching the
call so even when you're looking down at
your display you guys can see here on
this little demo that we were doing I'm
not looking at the camera but it looks
like I'm looking at the camera another
incredible demo that we did this was so
impressive Now using AI it's such a
buzzword at this point I feel like
people are like what does AI even mean
we were in this room where it was so
loud they had a train simulation they
had a bar scene simulation we were
talking into the microphone like looking
at the computer and everyone around was
talking loud collabing making all sorts
of noises and you did not hear any of
that background sound how's it going can
you hear me
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello
um I don't know how to converse with
someone that's not there even though I
talk on camera a lot I don't know what
kind of AI witchcraft it was doing but
it was so impressive it was probably one
of the most shocking demos that I've
seen in a very long time my sister and I
actually did a really fun podcast with
Pono so if you'd like to go watch it
I'll put a link in the description and
it was so wild when we did record this
we were talking to him and we had him do
a little clap like so that we could sync
the audio to the video and when he
clapped we didn't hear it at all and I
thought I was like okay something wrong
with my audio like what's happening
there's actually using the AI sound
filter to just remove the sound and I
was so shocked because when we actually
got a demo of that in person I was like
wow this is impressive now let's check
out the new Surface laptop 5. it of
course provides all-day battery life and
it now has Thunderbolt 4 with the latest
Intel Evo platform it's now 50 more
powerful than the previous it comes in a
13 and a half or 15 inch display option
with Dolby Vision IQ the speakers have
Dolby Atmos with 3D spatial processing
there's a front-facing HD camera and the
studio microphones and check out this
new beautiful sage color I'm not a huge
fan of the color green but for some
reason this sage and even the forest
color in the surface nine like I'm
obsessed it's so pretty you can
configure this with 8 16 or 32 gigs of
RAM and as far as storage you can get
256 512 or one terabyte solid state
drive now the 13 and a half inch comes
in the Platinum Sage matte black and
sandstone and the 15 inch comes in the
platinum and matte black another cool
thing about this room is they had
breakdowns of all of these items so you
could actually see the internals see how
everything was working and all of the
pieces and components inside and again
like I said the beginning of this video
one of the things that I love that
Microsoft Surface has done is their
attention to detail even getting a
chance to kind of see all of the steps
that go into the process of making these
devices was so fascinating from the CNC
machines to how they actually cut out
pieces of aluminum to test out
everything they have the capabilities
there to have an idea and then be able
to just make a prototype basically
overnight anyway so just a quick look at
some of the Microsoft products coming
out I hopefully will be able to get some
Hands-On so actually show them to you
but it was really great to get a chance
to go on this tour and I had so much fun
if you guys are new here hi I'm Justine
please subscribe so you'll be able to
see all of the videos that I post hit
the Bell to be notified when I post
those and of course leave me some
comments below and let me know what you
think about the new Surface products
I'll see you guys in my next video bye
foreign
[Music]